[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of beginner breakdown my
name is always it's Alex muellering and
it's been a while I apologize for
missing out on you so long we've had a
combination of tournaments and technical
difficulties but we are back and tonight
we're going to talk about some exciting
news how to get a promotion right you're
at work you're really trying to climb
the corporate ladder and this is this is
a chess video so we're actually going to
be talking about Pawn promotions here uh
which is still exciting right important
news and I did a a stream not too long
ago on some of the basic checkmates
right so if you're at the end of the
game and you have a rook and a queen you
can do a ladder Checkmate or just a
queen and just a rook we can look at
some of those as well if we have time
but I think it's important to start with
the end in mind in chess and a lot of
games times right you have to know a
little bit of openings at least the
opening principles because that's how
every game starts right every game of
chess you play is going to involve the
opening principles
and then a lot of the games you play if
you don't fall for some opening trap and
get checkmated really quickly are going
to devolve into some kind of middle game
where you and your opponent are trying
to play for tactical wins strategical
ideas
targeting weaknesses and that's really
important too but then there's also a
handful of chess games I'd say a decent
amount especially as you get slightly
stronger
they go all the way to end games most of
the pieces have been traded off and it's
about pressing very small advantages now
there's a lot of minutia and important
ideas in the end game but one of the
most fundamental if not the most perhaps
save the basic checkmates is how to
promote a pawn because the way you win a
lot of games when it's very close when
there's not a lot of material left is
one side maybe has a couple extra pawns
than the other and the goal is to try
and force one of them to win
now if there's multiple pawns on the
board I actually have a plan to do a
lecture in the coming weeks that
addresses if it's slightly more complex
multiple pawns may be a piece and what
to do in those types of situations
but tonight we're going to start with
just one right if one side has one Pawn
can they promote it or not and how do we
figure that out because if you know how
to promote a pawn and you know how to
checkmate with a queen then you can win
if you get an extra Pawn in an end game
so we're gonna that's kind of my theory
here with working backwards
and the first place I want to start is
what with what I call a known position
some people probably I think the more
technical term is a theoretical end game
and the way would we would differentiate
it is if I look at this position I would
say in my mind this is something I just
know I don't have to calculate anything
I don't have to look at the board and
think about it think about variations I
just know looking at this exact position
who will win and who will lose and I
know why
in this case it'd be better to say I
know whether or not white will win
because it's impossible for black to win
without a pawn it's insufficient mating
material so the Best Buy can hope for is
a draw but looking at this position I
can tell you without any thought who is
going to win and or if it's going to be
a draw and I keep saying who's going to
win in this case white is going to win
this game
uh now in this position it does not
matter whose turn it is to move so it
could be black to move it could be white
to move
um it doesn't matter whether my king is
on this square or on this square or on
this Square as long as my king is on one
of the three squares in front of the
pawn
um and it's in this specific orientation
I know White's going to win so here's
what I'm looking for right because this
is what we're going to keep working
backwards from the very backwards
working is when we actually promote to a
queen or something like that and then we
get a Checkmate but we're going to go
one step before that
in this case what I am looking for is my
king to be on the sixth rank my Pawn to
be on the fifth rank that's all I'm
looking for if I was playing as black it
would be the third and the fourth but
basically my king is two moves away from
the end of the board and the pawn is one
move behind it and the king is directly
defending the pawn from the front right
so it could be on the right or the left
or in the center here but it's somewhere
in front of the pawn one rank up
if all of those things are true it again
does not matter whose turn it is to move
all that matters is who has opposition
so we're going to come back to this
position in a moment but first we need
to talk about opposition because it's a
really basic idea
um very simply opposition is where
the two kings are in a straight line
facing each other that's all it is
um and there's different kinds so if
it's white to move here and I played the
move King to D4
our Kings would be in direct opposition
there is exactly one square in between
and we're in a straight line facing each
other
you could have indirect opposition as
well which would be if my king went here
to like a diagonal right there's one
square in between we're in a straight
line and indirect opposition will
usually transpose into direct opposition
so if black here we can look at any move
they can play if they go straight
backwards I can keep indirect opposition
and then something will again reflect
from there if they go say forwards I can
come this way and take opposition here
if they go to E6 here I can again take
opposition directly right here
if they went backwards I could do the
same so the person who takes opposition
is uh you know of all things being equal
the person who takes opposition is able
to maintain it and this is really
important because this is what
determines who's going to win and lose a
lot of King and pawn end games so we'll
come back to why that's important uh in
the general end game in a moment but I
want to return to this theoretical
position
so because I said here it doesn't matter
whose turn it is all that matters is who
has opposition and in this case let's
say it is White's turn to move
if it's white starting to move the
reason we can win this game is because
we can take opposition
Force our opponent's king to move and
this is maybe the the critical part the
reason why opposition is so important in
these end games is because in any end
game the primary objective is
controlling space now you might say well
isn't the main point to get a Checkmate
well it is but how do you get checkmate
you control the space your opponent's
king needs to go so in this case by
putting my king in opposition directly
in front in a line then the only way my
opponent can move is sideways or
backwards in this case my opponent is
already at the edge of the board so they
can just move sideways if they were
farther up backwards but critically my
opponent cannot move forwards they
cannot make any forward progress so we
are controlling the space of progression
this is why opposition import important
is breaking opposition strategically
called shouldering
I'm not sure if you heard that term it
would make sense we'll talk about
keeping opposition and kind of
transitioning and using it the term I'm
going to use is out flanking but we'll
get to that in a moment
okay so first here with opposition so
the problem black has is they have to
concede space
they're going to go left or right and
either way they go I am now going to do
what I call making the red carpet
so the way you win in a king and pawn
end game where one side just has one
Pawn right where you have one Pawn is if
you remember nothing else in this
lecture remember this you want your king
in front of your Pawn if your king is
behind the pawn or equal to it your
opponent often has chances to force a
draw but if your king is far enough
ahead of the pawn you can usually force
a win
again we'll get to the specifics in a
moment but with my king in front of the
pawn what I'm doing is I am laying out
the red carpet I am controlling the
spaces in front of the pond where it can
move forwards so this Pawn now in this
case I actually control every Square my
Pawn needs to move
in order to be promoted
so no matter what moves black plays here
there's actually nothing to stop me from
playing Pawn E6 E7 E8 queen or Rook or
whatever
so this is really critical I've laid out
the red carpet and the pawn is ready to
move forward and become the queen that
uh she was always meant to be
if in this position
because I said all that matters is
opposition but I also said we're winning
no matter what let's pretend black has
opposition here so I'm going to kind of
just play a few moves to triangulate my
king in order to force it so now my
opponent has opposition right black has
just moved to d8 and taken opposition
when this is the case if I'm on the
sixth Rank and my Pawn is on the fifth
right that's the first thing I need to
create then it doesn't matter that they
have opposition the timing is still
going to work out just right and what
you're looking for another way to
determine if you're going to be able to
force a win when you try and promote one
Pawn
is you want the pawn to reach the
penultimate rank so that's going to be
the seventh or the second depending on
what color you're playing as you want it
to get to the second to last Square
and you want it not to call check
here's what I mean
if the pawn pushes forward here black
has a choice
they can either step out of the way or
in the way if they go too far then when
I push the pawn I actually just control
all the squares so they can't come back
and stop me so really black here has to
step in front of my Pawn
and now notice when I push it to the
penultimate rank it is pushed without
calling check
what that means is because my opponent's
king is already in front of the pawn he
has to step out of the way
in this case the only way to do that is
to step to the side here and like before
I can move my king to create the red
carpet here and promotion is once again
inevitable
what happens if I try and do that in the
initial position where I am the one who
has opposition right in this case the
move I need to play to win this game is
King to E6 taking opposition so I can
make forward progress and make the red
carpet but if I try and push the pawn
right now it's actually now a draw
because black what black needs to do
is step in front of me and take
opposition if you step out of the way
then once again you allow me to step
forward so you can't let me control the
promotion Square so you take opposition
right keep my king from moving forwards
and now notice whenever I push the pawn
it's check
and because it's Czech the king is not
in front of the pawn the king is allowed
to step in front if you go the other way
I just promote so that's silly so the
king steps in front of the pawn and now
white is in uh zuk Swang which is a
German word
um essentially it means everything I do
is worse for me right I'm I'm only
hurting myself
the best move in this position if it
were possible would be to pass the turn
because if we look here at all the
squares my king can go to the only one
that defends the pawn is E6 right if I
step anywhere else opponent's king takes
the pawn it's just King versus King this
is a draw
so if I go to E6 to defend the pawn
the game is over and it's a draw this is
called a stalemate which is essentially
the king your opponent has no legal
moves but it's not check my Pawn
controls these two squares my King
Controls these three black has nowhere
to safely put the king but their king is
not currently in danger so it's not a
Checkmate it's a stalemate and the game
is a draw
so the two things we want to focus on
here right our goal in a king and pawn
end game is to achieve this position
right it doesn't matter whose turn it is
doesn't matter if the king is on F6 E6
D6 right just somewhere in front of our
Pawn
on the sixth rank with the pawn one row
below
and again if you're playing Black it's
three and four
and then you ask yourself do I have
opposition or does my opponent if I have
opposition I need to take it because if
you just push the pawn you will push it
with check and it's going to be a draw
so if I have opposition I take it my
opponent has to move and when they do I
step forward control the promotion
squares make the right carpet
if I do not have opposition
oops
then what I need to do is just get out
of the way the pond so we can imagine if
it's opposition something like this
right where the kings are doesn't matter
I just step my king out of the way
and the timing works out so that I can
push the pawn without calling check in
my king steps forward and promotes once
I have the queen I can go on to get a
checkmate
so this is our first known position or
theoretical end game uh the the contrast
would be like a practical end game which
is where we can look at it and take
educated guesses or have principles for
how we should play but we're still going
to have to calculate we don't know just
by looking at it unless you're like a
computer
or a really good player
um but generally anyone can look at this
position right if I know those rules my
king is on the six my Pawn is on the
fifth
um I know I'm gonna win
okay so this is what we're shooting for
we want our King in front of the pawn
and we want to reach a position like
this
so how do we actually do it
right we can imagine our Pawn is back at
the start and again the kings are on
their starting Square so maybe this is
not like the perfect setup for something
that would actually naturally happen in
a game but the good news is we're very
quickly going to understand the
principles that allow us to know whether
or not white is going to win or lose
here
because once again this is a theoretical
end game this is a known position and I
can tell you just by looking at it the
white winds
but the reason is slightly different
because now what I'm looking for are the
key squares
so in this case what I know is that if
white can get their King to one of the
key squares there are three of them I'll
show them in a moment if we can get to a
key Square we can win the game by force
so where are the key squares they are
the three squares think back to when we
were on the sixth and fifth right it's
the three squares immediately in front
of the pawn
but we need one more forward and we'll
show that in a moment so in this case
while the pawn is on E2 the key squares
are D4 E4 and F4 right the three right
in front of the pawn but one extra row
up
and again we'll talk about why we need
that extra space in a moment so
basically we just need to get our King
in front and all I have to do in this
position is calculate can I get my king
to one of those squares or can my
opponent stop me well let's imagine it's
white to move here
I will play King D2 let's say opponent
just goes forward King E3 Pony goes
forward I can I have my my pick and go
to any of these squares
so if it's white to move here white is
able to force a win
uh let's say it's black to move here
okay black goes let's say to E7 I step
forward black goes to let's say E6 I
step forward again
and black goes to E5
interesting
so because I put it as white to move I'm
actually going to just step to the side
as the first move and that's going to
then Force what would have happened here
notice that I now have lost opposition
because I took my time here
I didn't just go right away I can't get
to a key square and here's what's
critical the reason I cannot get to one
of these key squares no matter what I do
is because black has opposition remember
when one of the Kings takes opposition
what you're doing is you're controlling
the space in front of the opponent's
king so I can make plenty of King moves
but none of them go forwards
and it gets worse because if I just if I
step backwards then you can just follow
me and keep me behind the pawn we
already know I I'm losing progress there
if I step to the side then my opponent
can literally just copy me
and maintain opposition and I still have
no way to move forwards and I can dance
around forever but I'm never going to
get to step forward if my opponent
doesn't let me
and if I step behind the pawn
then I am in trouble this is now going
to now my opponent can force what we saw
when we were in that known position but
messed up right that when we took
opposition
or when we needed to take opposition and
didn't
what happened was I ended up having to
push the pawn forward to the seventh
rank it reached with check and my
opponents was able to slide their King
in front of the pawn so we can see that
happen here right let's just say my
opponent basically in this position once
the king can't get to a key Square once
I'm behind the pawn or next to it all
black wants to do is keep their King
directly in front of this Pawn
and or take opposition if they do one of
those two things then they can't lose
so let's watch okay I can't move my king
forward so I'm just going to push the
pawn black stays in front of the pawn
I move my king forward
black
uh
can't stay in front of the pawn here so
it takes opposition
all right I can move backwards but again
you just go back in front of the pawn So
eventually I will have to push it
and eventually as we work our way down
the board
we reach a position like this
where my opponent has successfully kept
me from making forward progress and here
right the rest of it is not so important
as long as black keeps my king from
getting in front of the pawn here black
has three legal moves and only one of
them is good black has to stay directly
in front of the pawn
why is that because if black moves to
the side f8 or d8 here
then I can approach with opposition I
regain it they've given it up
and now notice when they step out of the
way
I push the pawn without calling check
so black instead has to step straight
back and wherever I go instead of me
taking opposition black gets to meet me
once they've done that I can keep
running around but as long as black
follows this Rule and just goes straight
back to prepare to meet me with
opposition eventually I will run out of
moves that'll be a three-folder petition
or a 50 move Rule and I will have to
push the pawn
black will step in front and I will
either let them capture it or force a
stalemate
so that's what we're shooting to not
happen right we don't want I mean if
you're playing as uh the defending
player here that's it's important to
know right because sometimes you're in a
losing Pawn end game but we can still
Force draws if we're really careful and
pay attention to who has opposition who
can get to the key squares
we're going to look at a few more
examples of that but now let's quickly
look at what happens if we do this right
so we're going to move our King forwards
onto any of the key squares it doesn't
matter which
but I'm going to go straight forward and
take opposition right if I can take
opposition I don't have a good reason
not to
black has options they can step
backwards or they can go sideways but
because I have opposition they can't go
forwards
the natural moves are just to try and
move to the side right because if they
go backwards at very worst
I can take opposition and follow them
and I'm continuing to keep forward
progress
notice it's not really ever a danger for
me to get too far in front of my Pawn
the only way that gets bad is if I'm
getting too far ahead and my opponent's
like sneaking up already from the side
but as long as I'm in between my
opponent's king and my Pawn they they
have to get through me to get to it so
I'm not worried about that
so I can just keep following them back
as far as they'll let me and once I get
my king to the sixth remember all I have
to do is push the pawn and opposition
doesn't matter anymore right I know if I
have it here in this case I do I could
choose to take it
I know that I could win now this would
also work but I'm already where I need
to be in order to outflank and control
the red carpet
so that's kind of if they take it easy
on us but if black plays smart
and tries to give as little space as
possible
then it's white to move and I actually
have to be really careful here there's
only one move that makes progress so I
know I've kind of been just lecturing at
you but if you were in the chat here or
in person and want to suggest what you
think white should do in this position
please give your suggestion and I'll
kind of talk through some of those
answers so if you're watching this later
on YouTube you're always free to pause
the video at any time to try and think
through the position yourself before I
explain it so any idea what white should
do here to make progress
and feel free to take a guess if you're
not sure wrong answers are sometimes as
instructive as good ones
okay we have King F4 suggested in the
chat
king of four I think is a very safe move
one of the things you can always
remember is if we're on a key Square
then we can't lose the only time it's a
draw if we have our King on a key Square
the only time is literally if our
opponent is actively attacking our Pawn
because then if we're on a key score
we're too far away to defend it and they
take it any other situation if we are on
a key Square we can't lose so King F4 we
know at the very least we we're able to
hold a win
King F5 also suggested now we're moving
off a key square but this is actually
the best move
what's the reason well because remember
the goal of this end game like I said
earlier we need to keep our King in
front of the pawn
and we want to form the red carpet so
right now I control the square this
Square in front of the pawn once I go
here I control these squares and the
farther down the board I get the better
a chance I have of
forcing promotion
now once I've done this this is what we
would call out flanking
outflanking does something really
interesting because it actually gives up
opposition
but the thing about opposition is you
have to remember it's a means to an end
the reason we take opposition is because
we want to control space in this case
our opponent can take indirect
opposition here or direct opposition
here
if they take indirect opposition well
they're still conceding space and I can
just kind of follow them forward maybe I
shouldn't maybe I should have pushed the
pawn first but at the very least I'm not
in trouble by doing that I might just
not be making progress
if they take direct opposition
well the question we need to ask is
can we get to a key Square in this case
at the very least we can always step
back so we know we can force a win
and here some people would be tempted to
keep moving too far forward but remember
as well we need to keep our King in
between our opponent's king in this Pawn
if we let this King get too close we're
going to lose so here I would say let's
find a safe Square to push the pawn and
all you have to do is figure out once
the pawn is pushed
am I able to get to a key Square so this
is kind of the other thing to think
about in this type of end game
before you ever push the pawn you always
want to think can I forcibly get my king
onto one of the key squares from where
the pawn will be
so let's do some thought real quick in
this position the key squares are these
three so if I have no other move I can
always step onto a key square and I'm
doing okay
but I can also move the pawn I can move
it to E3 or because it's on the second
Rank and hasn't moved I can move it to
E4
and we can think whether one or both of
those moves are safe
if I move it to E3
where are the key squares for this Pawn
it's the three immediately in front and
then up a row so it's D5 E5 F5 in this
case my king is already on one of those
squares so I know I'm good so E3 is a
safe move to play here
what about E4 well if I push the pawn to
E4 the key scores will be D6 E6 and F6
and the question I need to ask is can
black play any move that keeps me from
going to any one of those squares right
if they cut off two of those squares but
not the third that's not good enough
they have to stop me from going to all
three
and the answer is no there's no move
that black can play to stop me from
going to F6 they can play King to D6 and
that stops me from getting to these two
squares but they cannot stop me from
going to F6
so E4 is also safe
again if you don't have a lot of time
and you're in an end game and you're not
sure to calculate it then you can always
play the safe move there's no harm in
that but the the principle here still
shows that this move is safe we have
defended the pawn black is going to have
to step out of the way and we can get
onto a key Square so we know we're still
doing okay
let's come back to the start
we're going to get our King in front of
the pawn
and I'm actually going to play a weird
move here I'm going to play King to D4
because this is also going to be
instructive
black is now able to take opposition
and remember I said we don't want to let
our opponent take opposition but we're
on a key Square so we know we're going
to win let's figure out why
has succeeded in taking opposition I
cannot move my king forward in any
meaningful way if I go to the side they
will follow and continue
but I have a way to get out of this trap
because I am not on a square immediately
in front of the pawn but there is that
one Gap Row in between I can take back
opposition not by moving my king
but by pushing the pawn
now notice what happens here I've pushed
the pawn and it's now black to move so I
have taken opposition you have to
concede space and whichever side you
move to I can move forward in the other
direction and get back onto that key
square if you weren't sure right if you
weren't sure about pushing the pawn you
can always double check that in your
head and say well wait a minute if the
pawn is going to go to E3
then the key squares will be these three
D5 E5 F5 can I force my king onto one of
those and we can think about it and say
well I push my Pawn to E3 black has to
play a move the only Square their King
can be to stop me from going to any of
those three is the square it's on right
now it has to step away from that square
and so I will be able to get onto one of
those
and once again I'm out flanking right
I'm allowing black to take opposition if
they want it but that doesn't matter
because I've gotten to the key square
and I'm able to keep making progress
towards the end of the board
so this is the reason why the key
squares are not right in front of the
pawn it's why they are
this one extra row ahead because
sometimes if your opponent takes
opposition you need to be able to break
the space with this breathing move
otherwise right say again let's say I
push opponent goes here I step this way
opponent goes here
I take opposition my opponent steps to
the side in this case
I need to outflank but if I don't if I
push the pawn
let's think about where the key squares
are once the pawn is on e4 the key
squares are D6 E6 F6 can my opponent
play any move to stop me from getting to
all three of those squares
yes black can take opposition here
and because I can't push the pawn I
can't waste the move
and it's now a draw
the reason and the last thing I'll cover
before we've kind of talked about
everything in the theoretical ideas and
then we'll get to some more kind of
noodly things but really if you
understand these fundamentals you're
going to win every King in Pawn end game
that is winnable uh with just King in
one Pawn again it gets more complex as
we add things
the reason it doesn't matter to have the
extra space on the sixth and fifth is
really interesting
let's take a look at that here so let's
say I don't flank
and I'm just going to push the pawn
okay in this case I pushed the pawn and
I can just make the promotion so let's
kind of triangulate a little bit
and now black has taken opposition
so why doesn't this matter well what
happens in the previous version right
the previous version when I pushed the
pawn black can step in front and I push
it again
and what can they do they can go
straight back
they can stay in front of the pawn
in this case if they try and do that
they're stepping off the board so it's
not legal so they actually have to move
out of the way that's why it's okay and
that very last row to do it when you get
your king of the six and the pawn the
fifth but otherwise right if we do that
one row earlier
so let's get back here
one row earlier it doesn't work anymore
because now when I step the king out of
the way and push the pawn
if they had to go hear white winds
but they can step back
and so it is a draw and the last when
they're on the last rank they can't make
that backward step
okay so that's really the kind of
fundamental principles of this end game
you need your king to get to a key
square and if you get to that
theoretical position King on the sixth
Pawn on the fifth or third and fourth if
you're playing as black then you know
you can win and it's all about
understanding opposition and those
waiting moves if you need to take it
back and again those key squares so keep
those ideas in your head
we're going to talk about just a handful
of complications but truthfully this is
like the basics if you understand these
fundamentals you can apply this to any
position it doesn't matter if the pawn
is over here or over here or over here
right we can always start to figure it
out using these ideas
okay so let's
quickly jump to
this position
in this position here it is White's turn
to move
can white win this game
or can black hold a draw
take a look try and figure out what you
think
and
and let me know and we'll discuss
anyone have a guess do you think white
can force a win or do you think and it's
white to move do you think black can
hold a draw
okay uh You Are Not Alone a few people
in the chat here as well
um let's think about this question the
way we're going to figure it out is
key squares so where are the key squares
if the pawn is on C3 right it's the
three in front but up a row
so B5 C5 D5
can we force our King onto any of those
squares well this is now a tricky
question because it's not one move right
we can't get our King onto those squares
in one move the question is can we get
our King onto any of those squares
period
well
what are the ways we can try right we
can try and move towards it if we move
away we already know we're going to be
behind the pawn and black is going to be
able to force a draw so the only chance
of doing this is to make some forward
move
and the same thing right if we push the
pawn our opponent just steps in front
and we can't do it
so what we need to think about is
opposition we can also sort of think
about forcing moves in a really weird
way because we're thinking about how
we're forcing our opponent to move their
King to stop us
so let's imagine I play I think what
looks like the most natural move King to
C4
just stepping in front of the pawn
well does black have any move that's
then going to keep me from getting onto
the key squares
in this case yes
black can take opposition here
and we know because I don't have a way
to push the pawn it's going to be a draw
so I can't go to C4 because then you
take opposition and stop me well I have
indirect opposition I can go King to B
for
in a straight line indirectly
and now what's really interesting is
black has to stop us from getting onto
B5
if they don't right if they play any
move that's let's just get onto B5 we're
on a key square and we know we're going
to win and the only move black can play
to stop us from doing that is to go to
C6
but now
we can take opposition ourselves King to
C4 and black has to concede space
we outflank
and we've made it to a key Square so in
this position we actually can win but we
have to be very careful right that's the
thing with some of these end games is
one move is the difference between
winning and losing right this is I think
why end games are often harder than any
other phase of the game because it's
very rare I mean there are blunders but
it's very rare that just one single move
is going to dramatically affect the
course of the game in the same way that
it does in an end game
so keep an eye on indirect opposition
and again I would think about this just
as a matter of these forcing moves right
I want to get onto one of these three
squares and so if I'm playing a move
like this well you have to stop me
and then I can take opposition
okay so now that we've looked at that
one again the idea of King B4 take
opposition
and wherever our opponent goes they
concede space we keep forming the red
carpet and we are going to make our way
down to the edge of the board
one more thing that can be a little
tricky here
in this case it is white to move
and this is a hard one we're actually
going to try and defend here right
because black has the pawn it's white to
move the question is do we have any move
that holds a draw or can black force a
win
let's see what we can figure out can we
hold the draw as white or can black
force a win
and use the steps that we've been
looking at before
to to try and identify that answer
okay so it looks like uh well looks like
it's about half and half
some people are saying a draw some
people are saying a win
so we're really unsure let's once again
I'm going to use the way I've been
thinking about this let's think about
the key squares maybe the first question
is is the king and Pawn on the rows
there need to be no the Pawn's not on
the fourth the king's not on the third
so it's not theoretically already a win
and then there's also this question of
key squares so right now with the pawn
on D5
the key squares for black are C3 D3 E3
if black can force their King onto any
of those squares black will win the game
so do we have any move that stops that
well this is where a really funny
technique called distant opposition
comes in so we talked about opposition
before as being the Kings facing the
straight line you can actually figure
out opposition even if they're not in a
straight line I've done that I think in
a previous lecture so feel free to check
that out I think it's called opposition
and outflanking
but for the purposes of this let's just
think about straight lines
we can still calculate uh who has
opposition if the two are in a straight
line so we're going to come back to this
example in a moment but let's return to
our idea of opposition here in general
right in this case when white has
opposition what does that mean that
means the kings are facing each other in
a straight line there's one square in
between and it is your opponent's turn
to move right if you have taken
opposition your opponent has to move
we can actually generalize this even
more because it's not just one square
it's even or odd if there are
an even number of squares in between you
and your opponent and you're in a
straight line
again we can talk about those
non-straight lines and other uh another
day but if you're in a straight line if
it's an odd amount of squares
between you and your opponent and it's
your turn to move then you don't have
opposition if it's an even amount of
squares and it's your turn to move you
do because notice when we if it's white
here we have two squares in between it's
even it's our turn to move
and when we move closer we turn it into
one which is odd so you want to be the
one moving towards your opponent when
you have an even number of squares in
between the two kings and you want your
opponent to have to move when there's an
odd number because if it's just one then
it's obvious if it's three
it's maybe less clear but we can still
figure it out in this case I just move
back so it's Black starting to move
they're moving with an odd number of
squares and notice if they make any
forward move we take opposition
if they move backwards we can move
forwards and keep the same line and the
same number of squares so that doesn't
change anything
and if they just move to the side what
do we do here well
we can move to the side because if we
move forwards now there's an even number
and we don't want them to move with the
even number in between
so I can move to the side and maintain
opposition
so that's the idea of distant opposition
why is this relevant right because in
this case it doesn't matter right we
know we're on a key Square we're going
to promote here's where it does matter
in this case
we can take distant opposition which
means we are going to keep it when they
move closer if we move our King to C2
the natural move here we lose because
after King to C2 there is an odd number
of squares or sorry there's an even
number of squares between the two Kinks
and it's our opponent's turn to move
they're going to move
and take opposition
the pawn is promoting
so what do we do instead if we move some
suggested like B2 B2 doesn't work
because they can also still take
opposition they can also just take
indirect opposition and then cut
straight to a key Square
but if we play King to C1 here
there is an odd number of squares in
between the Kings and whoever moves
forward in this case our opponent has to
we're going to move our King to meet
them with opposition
so in this case right if you push the
pawn the king's behind the pawn but if
you move the king anywhere
I take opposition
and you have not yet made it to the
third rank you are one row or one rank
too far behind with both the king and
the pawn if it was one more forward then
you would win but in this case you're
not far enough forward
so that is a confusing concept sometimes
if you need to after this video go back
and rewatch that section or think about
it a little more that's okay distant
opposition is tricky but it's really
important because it can be the
difference in this case between winning
and losing a game like this a question
oh yeah so King D6
anytime they go behind the pawn right
all we have to do is get our King in
front right because here the key squares
haven't moved the key squares are still
C3 D3 and E3 so as long as we can stop
their King from getting to one of those
squares we're fine in this case we can
just actually step in front of the pawn
so anytime they let us step in front
something like this we know that our
King is in front of the pawn and they
can't get far enough forward so this is
always going to be a draw because of
what we looked at in the beginning right
they can't ever move their King forward
we can step so if they push the pawn if
we keep our King in front and take
opposition when possible we're
eventually going to get to this same end
game and here's the critical move right
you want to stay in front of the pawn
here because when they step out of the
way we need to meet them with opposition
if they meet us with opposition then
they're going to push without it being
checked and we have to step out of the
way so we go straight back stay in front
of the pawn and prepare to meet black
with opposition wherever they go
when they push the pawn right they can
try and delay but we always just go
right back in front of the pawn
and prepare to meet them with opposition
and inevitably when they push we step in
front because if you push the pawn with
check it's going to be a draw black now
either forces a stalemate or they step
far enough away that I can just take the
pawn so good question
okay
uh final thoughts here again I know
there's a lot of just principles have
been thrown at you I encourage you to
practice this this is one of the really
nice things with a website like leeches
or any other just database or software
that you can just set up a position very
quickly right here I can go to a board
editor and you can do that yourself as
well and set up a position with just two
kings and a pawn and practice this you
can play against a friend you can play
against the computer and if you win when
you're or sorry if you lose when you're
not supposed to or Draw you're not
supposed to you can go back and figure
out what did I do wrong how could I have
gotten to a key square and try and
figure that out
okay a few final clarifications first
all this is different when it's a rook
pond so everything I've said applies if
the pawn is on any of these files B
through G but if it is on an edge of the
board
the math changes
basically I I don't have the perfect
rule but the closest I can get for it is
if your opponent's king can step into
the corner where the pawn is meant to
promote
then it is a draw
so the re and I'll show this right so
let's say in this case I I can take
opposition but it doesn't actually
matter we can actually it's kind of
funny we can see it right in this
position right I can take opposition
and what's the goal with opposition well
I want to force you out of the way so I
can move forward
but I can't step off the board
okay so I can't make forward progress
with the King
that's unfortunate but even if you let
me right even if you let me get all the
way as far close as I want
I still run into a problem
as long as you stay on the corner and
basically if you're defending here you
just want to play King to the corner
where the pawn is trying to go and then
move either towards the pawn or one to
the side and then back and you just want
to do that for the whole game
and the problem will be that this will
always force a draw if I push with check
then
it's the same problem as before it's
just this board part is gone it's either
a stalemate or you take the pawn
but even if I push without check so
again let me kind of triangle a little
bit here
if I push without check
it's still a stalemate because in this
case the move I was hoping you would
play is King diagonally off like this
way but on the other side which is again
off the board so because you don't have
enough space to step out of the way of
the pawn it's going to be a stalemate
every time if the king is able to get to
the corner
so that's kind of the first
consideration there is one additional
one
um which yeah we got enough time I'm
going to quickly flip over here
you can actually Force this to be a draw
even if you can't get your king to the
corner right in this case I would say
it's white to move
even though Black's King is both in
front of the pawn and stopping me from
getting to the corner you can the key
squares don't really apply to The Rook
con so don't think about those
um
you can also keep the king because there
is no space off the board we can use
that to our advantage here and as long
as we keep the king trapped on the edge
the pawn can never promote right because
the pawn can't push through the king
so here I would play the move King to F2
taking once again opposition stopping
the king from making progress and I'm
basically again controlling the space I
want to lock you out of
and black is stuck right if you push the
pawn
then I can play King to F1 and you have
a really nasty choice you can either
play King to G3 and I will zip over to
the corner and we already saw why this
is a draw
so you can also try instead to stay in
front of the pawn but now
you are slowly going to be suffocated
because if you keep bouncing back and
forth It's repetition eventually you
push the pawn
and I can play King to F1 taking
opposition
and here it's a stalemate
but it's funny because normally the
stalemates are we're committing them
when we have the extra Pawn here black
has the extra Pawn it's just stuck and
the king is stuck because our King has
opposition so if you can lock the if
you're down the pawn and you can lock
your opponent's king onto the wall you
can also get a drawn that way so keep
that in mind too Rook pawns are
notoriously problematic
um one kind of middle game tip for you
is if you have the option to trade some
pawns and you can force your opponent to
keep a rook pawn and you can get a
center Pawn or a flank Pawn
often it will be a better for you in an
end game so that's a nice thing to keep
in mind
okay so those are kind of the two
complications of The Rook pawns but
again anytime it's not a rook Pawn it's
very very simple to not always simple
but we can always understand the
principles at play in figuring out who's
going to win or not right any given
position all we have to do is ask
ourselves can
well first if it's already on like the
sixth and fifth if it's far enough down
the board you don't have to think about
moves just you say is this the known
position I know is the King on the sixth
the pawn on the fifth and the opponent's
king on the final rank or again third
fourth and first if you're playing as
black
if that's the case do I have opposition
if so I take it and out flank control
the squares right um here it's probably
better if I actually display this yet
again right if I have opposition
then I take it out flank to control the
red carpet and push the pawn down the
board
if I don't have opposition
that's not what I want to do
if my opponent has opposition then I
want to Simply step out of the way and
the timing works that I can push the
pawn without calling check
once again control the promotion Square
farther back all the question is is can
I control the key squares so with
something like this
oops this one uh I figure out where the
key squares are it's the three squares
right in front of the pawn but up a row
because we want that one row of
breathing room in case we need to waste
the move when our opponent takes
opposition
so if I can get to one of these key
squares I know that I can win if my
opponent can stop me from getting to any
of them then my opponent can hold a draw
in this case I know that I will have
time to make it and once I do it's
simply a matter of out flanking
and knowing when it's safe to push the
pawn right in this case some people
might still make the mistake of playing
Pawn to C4
well when the pawn is on C4 the key
squares are V3 and my opponent can take
opposition there is no space between me
and the pawn and this would be a draw
I could play this one because I'm on
this key Square that's always safe
um
and the one kind of final position I'll
look at with you is
I'm actually going to put it back here
we'll talk about one thing that's not
exactly the the key Square's idea
um let's do
this
so if you get to a position like this
right where again your opponent is kind
of chasing after you you really have to
know what to do but it's very simple we
say if I get too far away I want to
control the space in front but if I let
the king step in I'm going to lose the
pawn so I want to push the pawn and I
just have to ask myself before I do can
I get my king to a key Square in this
case yes you can't stop him from getting
to B6 so I will push
and I will move forward and say
something like this
you can also get into some confusions
here you could try and maybe repeat and
get confused but notice we actually have
a few ways to win this one we can just
push the pawn
and then realize we can take opposition
we can also say even if I don't have
opposition
my king is on the sixth
so if I get my Pawn to the fifth even if
my opponent somehow managed to take
opposition
I'm still on the right ranks so I can
still step out of the way and the timing
works out because in this case my
opponent cannot move their King
backwards they have to step forwards
okay
hopefully that has been helpful for you
the final things we're going to look at
is just kind of a little addendum I want
to add in here that also has to do with
one king and one Pawn promoting so it
seems important a lot of you might
already know this but this is the rule
of the square
if your king is just hopelessly far away
from your Pawn often this will happen in
end games where there is some
simplification
so we trade some of our pieces and one
side keeps a pawn and it's like okay
well now it's a race situation I don't
know if I'm going to promote or if my
opponent's going to get to me there's an
easy way to figure out who is going to
win this race right in this case let's
say it's White's turn to move
what you want to do is you want to
figure out when it's the king's turn to
move will the king be able to step into
an imaginary square and here's what I do
I say where will the pawn be
and then I draw a diagonal line I mean
you can also just in your head draw to
see where the square promotes a diagonal
line to the edge of the board right kind
of pretend it's a bishop where would it
land if it hit the edge of the board and
then you connect those coordinates so in
this case it would be if I really was
bad at visualization I could say okay
the pawn diagonally would be on E8 here
it would be on B8
here it's on B5 and then B and E would
be or sorry E8 and B5 would have the
child of E5 so this would be that square
if it were blacks trying to move so if
it's Black starting to move black can
stop the pawn because the question is
can black step into this Square
if it's wides starting to move then the
pawn is going to be on B6 when it's
black starting to move
our coordinates will be B6 B8 and d8 and
then we cannot kind of triangulate that
to D6
can Black's King step into that square
no so White's going to win this race
and here let's quickly show that if it
had been Black's turn to move so I'm
going to move my king
in this case now we see the square okay
it's the king's trying to move so where
is the pawn it's here this is our square
and the King can step in because the
king is stepping onto an edge we know
that black is going to make it just in
time one move in time
we promote and it gets captured
so it's a really quick way again you're
always fine to just calculate and count
and think okay well it's got one two
three and there's one two three four
you're always trying to do that
sometimes I will kind of get confused in
my head so having this quick little rule
I can just apply and again no without
having to calculate anything I think
it's just a helpful little tool
let me give another example here
in this case it is black to move the
question is can black stop the pawn from
promoting or will the pawn make it in
the nick of time
what do we think is this a win for white
because we promote safely or is it a
draw because black is going to catch the
pawn
all right somebody says he can walk into
the square
some people say black can catch some
people say it's a draw
win so we're really mixed this one is
really tricky
this one is very tricky why is it tricky
it's because when the pawn moves it's
going to move twice
so the way to catch that the way to
account for that is when it's the Pawn's
first move and it's going to move twice
the question we asked before was where
is the pawn when the king moves towards
it right here the king is moving so we
ask where's the pawn
but because it can move two I just cut
up a square so I say let's imagine the
pawn is here because it's next move it's
going to go here whether it moves one or
two
so on H3
we go to the edge of the board
the king cannot step into this box the
king is going to be one move too slow
Let's test it out
just looking close
the king is one move too slow again in
my opinion way easier to figure out that
quick Square than to try and count okay
you go here you go here you go here I'm
way more likely to lose track of it so
that is my advice for figuring out these
positions the way we can apply this
because again A lot of times people like
how does this apply to my real chess
games I'm never going to get a position
like this well
he might get a position like this
seems realistic in this position it's
White's turn to move
the question is should we trade Queens
because black is up material so normally
when you're down material you don't want
to trade
but we notice even though black has
three uncontested past pawns on the side
we have two that are very close to
promotion and only one in the way
so the question we need to ask ourselves
is after we make all these trades
is the black king gonna be in the Square
you can now apply this to a middle game
position I mean this is still an end
game but we can apply it in a more
complex position
in my mind I would think of it like this
and you can obviously pause the video or
take a thought here if you think we
should be able to win
but the answer here is yes and here's
how we figured out if we trade the
Queens black is forced onto F6
if we don't trade the Queens we might
still be able to win but we also have to
deal with them having a queen and some
extra pawns and maybe we just lose
so we can calculate I'm going to force
this queen trade and the King ends up
here
I push the pawn
it is the King's turn to move with the
pawn on B6
here is the Box
of a square the king cannot make it into
that square
but it's complicated because you can
take the pawn
but if you take it I take back and
nothing has actually changed I still
have a pawn that's in this box
so I know if I make this trade
the king is one move too slow and white
is actually winning this game this is
how we can apply some of these rules
right you could do a similar one I don't
think I attached it in this example but
a similar study you could consider
like we could get rid of all of these
pieces and just say it's like a 2V1 or a
3v4 and figure out when we make these
Pawn trades is my king going to be able
to get to a key square or can my
opponent stop me all right we can apply
all these same principles these
theoretical end games because the goal
is
chess is all about calculation
the whole game is one big calculation
battle and there's some differences
right some openings there's memorization
and there's principles and there's kind
of theory but anything we can do to help
us reduce how much we have to calculate
is really helpful so in my mind I would
rather be able to look at a position
like this
and say I only need to calculate Queen
takes queen king takes Pawn to B6 that's
all I need to think about to know if I'm
winning or if it's a draw or if Black's
winning because if I can get that far
that's way easier than me calculating
all the way down
so these steps hopefully can help you
reduce the amount of things you need to
calculate and focus on the stuff like
this where it's more complex how can you
simplify how can you use your forcing
moves and how can you find the Right
Moves In your games
so that is all the time we have for
tonight I hope this has been helpful for
you in navigating some of these really
tricky key and pawning games and I hope
to do a little more on this in the
future with maybe adding some extra
Pawns in and again how do we deal with
this complexity and navigate it all
right uh I hope to see you again in the
future and please stick around because
our grand master Danish boros will be
streaming right after this uh
grandmaster's Choice until next time
thank you
[Music]
foreign